hello everyone my name is reto meier and
welcome to this week in Android
development November 16 2012 we've had a
huge couple of weeks in Android
development developments so this week's
episode is stuffed full of them the
turducken I'll be feasting on next week
at Thanksgiving earlier this week
lightning reflexes and nerves of steel
will prerequisites for picking up a
shiny new Nexus 4 7 or 10 when the
latest members of the Nexus family
appeared will be briefly for sale on
Google Play you can't have a new
framework without a new API to go along
with it so tuesday also saw the grand
unveiling of android api level 17
featuring the new daydream api lock
screen widgets and improved renderscript
computational performance a new API is
no fun without a set of new tools to use
with it so don't forget to check out the
latest tools revision that's our 21 for
those keeping count that's also
available for download now it features
the incredibly cool multi config editor
more app templates and the new UI
Automator test framework if all these
new releases has inspired you to hone up
on your Android development skills but
you're not sure where to start check out
the newly rearranged Android training on
the Android developer side it's been a
busy few weeks for Android developers
life too with the premiere of table flip
with me the first episode focused the
dark heat of a thousand dying sons at
apps with exit buttons check out the
youtube video to learn why later that
weekend and I looked at instant
messaging apps on the App clinic before
Roman Nick and Adam took their take on
what it takes to make the ultimate
unified messaging app they also invited
the Android design community to become
part of Android design in action
starting with the community hangout in
an Android design stencil giveaway then
earlier today I flew solo for a personal
fitness app clinic the irony of which
cannot possibly be overstated we're
taking a break next week as we search
for in whose review of one of the less
well reviewed gps tracking apps that
resulted in him being lost in the
backwoods of the Sierra Nevada forests
we will be back after stuffing ourselves
stupid with Thanksgiving fair want to
help us decide which apps to review when
we come back check out our trailer board
a bit ly / app clinic trailer to
nominate your apps and cast your votes
will have an abbreviated lineup on
Android developers live next week as
most of our team is traveling cooking or
eating but don't forget you can find
please schedule for next week's live
shows at Google developers live today's
live wallpaper was fancy fallen quads
from Lee well calm and know that if I
didn't know better I'd hang my hat right
there my name is reto Meier thanks for
watching